i've not read
white fragility or how to be anti-racist
please don't
how would you describe those books to me
well white fragility is the second
worst book ever written i mean literally
the in terms of the books that i've
encountered i read one book once when i
was about 20
that was
supposedly explaining how various old
hollywood cartoon characters got their
names but the person who wrote it didn't
have any ideas and so it was things like
well daffy duck was probably called
daffy duck because of his daffy
personality i remember back then
thinking this is the worst book i have
ever read now the second worst book i've
ever read was when two summers ago i
read white fragility just a truly
horrific
tome where the idea is that whites need
to sit down in a circle and confront
their complicity in an inherently racist
society and understand that they're
being subtly racist in just about
anything that they do or say
and what you're supposed to do once you
go from there is not clear and and
deangelo even says
to be hastily thinking about solutions
like what are we going to do in society
where do we go from here that's wrong
you're supposed to quote unquote do the
work of identifying the racism within
you and she's very careful about saying
she's not trying to be hostile she's
saying that you can't help being racist
in this society she's not condemning but
still the question is what in the world
would all of this zen-like
self-discipline do
for poor black people who actually need
help and you can tell that she
doesn't give a good god damn and when
asked what she thinks of black people
who don't agree with her she basically
calls us uncle toms so that's that's all
there is and then with um candy
one doesn't want to go too far into
his work and i avoided doing so too much
until about a year ago when he started
calling me out but kendy is somebody who
thinks in binaries he's not reflective
he thinks in you know binary oppositions
he's his stuff reminds me of book
reports essentially
and his idea is that if you're not being
actively anti-racist then you qualify as
racist now i don't even know what that
means but that's the way he writes and
he is the um he's the kind of black
person who grew up actually thinking of
white people as devils that's a black
nationalist kind of perspective and he
studiously makes sure to let you know
that he's let go of it now but that way
of looking at things informs the way he
sniffs the world and you can listen to
his talks and see that he really does
think that we live in this country that
is stamped from the beginning with
racism and all about racism now and he
comes up with these prescriptions for
what should be done in this country that
quite simply are those of
someone who does not know much about how
modern societies work and has never had
to think about it and i didn't talk this
way about him for a good couple years
because i'm not inherently mean but he's
been so nasty to me and he started it
that i've decided okay i'm gonna have to
be honest he's not 25 he's old enough to
take it and so really kendy is somebody
who was working humbly doing his best
and he was abruptly thrust into the
spotlight two summers ago and he's doing
his best but i
am baffled as to what sort of leadership
he's gonna propose because he doesn't
think subtly that's it so those are
those are the two people and i don't
you know um they have sold a great many
books and gotten very rich and that's
fine with me but the thing is if you
read the two of those books it's very
hard to see how they fit into
america as it actually is as opposed to
this
1950 that robin d'angelo thinks we've
never gotten past or practically the
1850 that kennedy seems to almost wish
we were still in because his dichotomies
would apply more gracefully so yeah
they're both um i frankly consider both
books utterly worthless um candies i
wouldn't put on this worst book ever
list i just think that there's not a
whole lot of there there d'angelo's book
as i've said elsewhere should be used as
furniture it's a really it's a nice size
for if you've got a wobbly table you
could put that book under and your table
would be solid truly terrible piece of
work but apparently some people disagree
with me
is there a sense that these people
would be afraid to admit victory
that if they were to achieve some sort
of equality they're basically putting
themselves out of a job
yeah um i wouldn't put it that way it's
not that they're thinking i wouldn't
have a job
if any if they had to admit that things
were not the way they say it would
deprive them of purpose essentially i'm
sure that both both of those people and
people like them at this point could
retire they never have to work again
it's not about having a livelihood and i
don't sense that for example with either
d'angelo or candy that they especially
like attention
looking at themselves on tv i don't
think that's either one of them but if
they had to admit that america is not
the way they depict it they wouldn't
have anything to do you know all of us
as somebody told me when i was first
starting out we all have a few arrows in
our quiver essentially there's a few
things that we do and say and if you
can't use them what else are you going
to do and you know robyn deangelo's in
her 60s for example kendy is pushing 40
you can't completely reform yourself
after a certain point and nobody wants
that and i think just in general you you
have a sense of your purpose on this
earth well if the job is already done
what are you going to do in your spare
time i can understand why they can't let
it go but that means that there have to
be voices speaking directly
against people like that when they're
less correct and less useful than many
people are being told what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you